it was too much last night I said this
is too much this morning I said this is
too much and now I realize it's too
much you should not buy this video card
or really probably any of the high-end
cards right now this is the 570 TI it's
the it's just the box it's okay the
market is in chaos the conditions are at
an all-time low for consumers and it
benefits the entire industry including
us if everybody mindlessly consumes but
we're telling you not to be a part part
of that cycle this is not the time to
buy an Nvidia video card they say this
will be $750 but we don't believe it in
fact some partner models have already
been spotted at $11,000 with plenty of
others coming in at $ 850 to 900 we even
heard of one partner model that'll have
an MSRP above
,000 that's more than a 480 that's
insane so Nvidia says this is an RTX 570
TI but it's really more like an RTX 480
V3 or V4 if you count the unlaunched
4802 GB which was a 470 TI the tldw up
front is that the 580 is about 12 to 16%
better than this in some of the 4K
gaming scenarios we tested the 5070 TI
is about 28 to 35% ahead at Best of the
4070 TI again in those 4K scenarios but
it comes down into the 20% to 28% range
when you're at 1440p additionally the
lead over the 470 TI super which is
really the one that's easy to lose track
of but is important because it's the
closest sort of price analog from the
most recent generation that is only 7.8%
to 20% in a lot of 4K situations were
commonly 12 to 16% and the worst case
one we saw was an impressively bad 3.9%
better for the 5070 TI versus the 4070
TI
super so again based on the pricing
we're expecting for launch and also kind
of just the MSRP we don't think you
should buy this video card honestly you
should even really watch this video see
you later if you agree you'll miss the
memes that we've packed into all the
charts there's some good ones in there
but hey we're going to save you the time
and just that's how we feel about it
it's this is really just not exciting
and part of the problem here is that
Nvidia while it has become fat and
monopolistic is facing a competitor that
has decided to just literally won't even
compete in the high end that's as much
as AMD said and Intel's not there yet so
it's just Nvidia
and it's so much Nvidia that the 580
card to the 470 card is a difference
that has now been subdivided several
times like the 480 and the 470 TI which
was a 480 12 GB originally already
subdivided it likewise the 480 super
created another subdivision the 4070 TI
super created yet another subdivision
and now the 5070 TI creates a further
subdivision there are so many
subdivisions in this block that it'll
have an HOA by next
week I'll be here all night in one of
our tests we saw an average gap between
cards in this upper end of 6.7 to 8 FPS
card to card depending on which cards
you want to count what this really means
is that the only relevant factor is
price except maybe vram in a few places
where it diverges which is becoming
fewer that'll matter more for
professional users but even vram has
mostly been split into the sort of 90
class and then everyone else the 5070 TI
is often the same performance as the 40
80 which is the same performance as the
480 super it is uh hardly an improvement
over the 4070 TI super which was close
to the same MSRP and this aligns with
what has appeared to be nvidia's launch
strategy of just flooding sort of each
category of card so you got to step
every 50 bucks for another couple FPS
meanwhile AMD strategy because they're
not cleaning this either has apparently
been Nvidia minus $50 equals MSRP it's a
formula so commonplace they should teach
it in math classes now anyway let's get
into it we brought you this video we
figured an unhinged launch required an
equally unhinged ad so we placed our own
you can use code about [__] time for
10% off anything on the store like our
gn15 large anti-static mod mats that
we've been selling for about 8 years now
now is a better time than ever to take
apart an old video card and repaste it
and maintain it with a cleanout to
extend its life and the modmat gives you
a screw tracking diagram and pin outs to
make things easier you might also like
our silicone soldering and project mats
which are perfect surfaces to incinerate
your 12volt high power cables on because
they're extremely heat resistant mats
the mats are available in a GN blue
yellow a fire red and toxic green which
seems fitting today you might also like
our seven-piece sharp edge resin dice
kits with embedded snowflake the cap
Miniatures or our e-waist inductor
series dice with embedded copper coil
inductors within each die each kit comes
with a high quality wooden box that we
designed with an integrated roll tray
and with latches Plus either a snowflake
the cat MTG style card or Goblin
creature token finally consider our
copper plated stainless steel Mule mugs
worst case if you don't like it you can
always slap some thermal paste on the
bottom and use it to cool your GPU head
over to store. Gamers nexus.net for all
of that and more and remember use code
about [__] time now this is the 570
TI Asus Prime which we assume they named
it that way because they're trying to
get Logan Paul's attention or something
or maybe it has a lightt which The
Gamers crave the RTX 570 TI has 8960
Cuda course 16 GB of gdr 7 and a 256bit
bus the memory spec is identical to the
80 with the 580 having more caor but
being a significant cut down from the
5090 more than we've seen typically we
covered the full specs in a separate
video we'll link that below if you care
about that it's basically the brochure
and the spec sheet pricing is going to
be the biggest problem for this GPU we
made some tables recently that show the
price change since launch which was like
a couple weeks ago for the other 50
Series card sorry cards cards there's
technically more than one I mean like
two or three is it it does become plural
at that point so so for the supply being
non-existent the 5090 and 580 as we
showed in our table in the other video
have skyrocketed alongside things like
insane combo packs that might not even
be compatible with each other to push it
all into true fomo territory and to
accompany its fake frames and video's
fake prices say the 5070 TI will launch
at MSRP of $750 we know again of one
board partner that is north of a grand
for one of its models this gets worse
considering the lower overall price of
$750 means that the proportional price
hike from the Baseline feels a lot worse
especially as you get into the type of
buyer who is going to be trying to
Target something that would
traditionally be considered mid-range
although $750 for GPU today kind of
feels more like what a high-end purchase
used to be and that's even with
inflation but there's really not a lot
of ground to cover here that we haven't
already at some point we've got the
paper launch video we have the fake
prices video we have a separate video I
don't know if it'll be up or if it's the
next day but for DLS S4 image quality
and stuff like that so you can check
those out if you want all that stuff
let's just get into the data now for the
testing today we had to remove a couple
cards from the charts to make some space
we removed the 3090 and the 3090 TI if
you want the data for those check the
5080 video it's got all that hasn't
changed now to the first game in Final
Fantasy 14 at 4K the RTX 5070 TI landed
at 97 FPS average with lows at 83 and 80
that's the same as an RTX 480 which
under normal conditions might sound like
a generational Improvement on the
arbitrarily named gpus instead what we
have is total generational stagnation
because the 5070 TI will regularly sell
at prices at least for now approaching
what the 4080 was even at only a slight
elevation to $850 like for partner
models that are on the better end of
pricing the card is simply too close to
the last generation performance
equivalent the 7800 XTX outperforms the
5070 TI by 7.4% with the 580 16% ahead
and the 5090 87% ahead of the 5070 TI as
for the 700xt hellhound which was the
cheapest partner model for a while
that's at 82 FPS generationally by name
the 570 TI improves on the 4070 TI by
34% but the 47 TI super is the more
recent price replacement so the lead
over the 470 TI super is just 133%
that's stagnation we have the RTX 2070
super in a future test but the 1070 is
in here if you want something older the
improvement over the Pascal GTX 1070
which is now 9 years old is 332 here at
1440p the 570 TI ran at 187 FPS average
1% and .1% lows are where they should be
based on other results so there's
nothing exceptional here the 5070 TI
outranks the 470 TI super by just 15 FPS
or only 9% sadly this is one of the
better ones but that's still brutal and
it makes this one of the most boring
improvements possible when considering
the MSRP similarity and that's before
you go and get ripped off for more as
for the other 70 class cards the 5070 TI
is uplifted with the 4070 TI is 44% then
72% on the 3070 TI 94% on the 3070 non
TI and 37% on the 1070 The Uplift has
diminished for each of these as
resolution came down to 1440p despite
the 5070 TI not being anywhere close to
a CPU ceiling amds rx700 XTX leads the
570 TI by 133% up from 7% at 4K the 570
TI also leads the 700 XT by just 9% here
at 1080p things get even worse the 570
TI leads the 470 TI super by only 6% or
just 15 FPS average over the 470 TI non
super which remains an absolutely absurd
distinction to need to make where only
seeing a 16% advantage on the 5070 ti no
wonder NV video wants everyone to type a
frame rate into a calculator and
multiply it artificially for MFG the new
card is just 10% over the 700 XT then
74% over the 3070 TI Blackmouth W call
is up now tested at 4K we're removing
the experimental chart labeling and feel
that this test has had enough public
visibility to clear that bar the 5070 TI
ranan at the exact same frame rate as
the 480 Nvidia has basically re-released
the 480 again and the price isn't even
that different and in some case not
different at all in other words Nvidia
has now released three RTX 480s this is
the third one and actually it would be
the fourth if they stuck to their
original plan of the 480 12 GB instead
of the 4070 TI at some point it just
seems like this is too much it was too
much last night I said this is too much
this morning I said this is too much and
now I realize it's too much the 7900 XTX
matches the 570 TI here the difference
is a relevant and unnoticeable against
the 470 TI sup 45 FPS average the 570 TI
leads by 133% or 27% over the 4070 TI
nons super and similarly over the 7900
XT the lead over the 3070 TI is 81% at
1440p the RTX 480 V3 or maybe V4 ran at
87.2 FPS average with lows at 74.9 and
70.3 the third iteration of the 4080
isn't the best one though the first
version of the 480 and the second
version of the 480 are within error of
each other but on the V3 aka the 55070
ti Nvidia has enabled multi Fiat
generation to make it more interesting
only Gamers know that joke the memes
will continue until morale improves
which apparently will be never the rx700
XTX is about the same as the 5070 TI
here with the 4070 TI super just below
it the 5070 TI is only 10% ahead of the
470 TI super and 20% ahead of the 470 TI
with a similar lead over the 7800 XT at
1080p the 5070 TI is again roughly tied
with the 700 XTX although credit to
Nvidia for having improved 0.1% lows
just not by an amount anyone would
notice in play the frame time pacing is
still good on both the 480 super and 480
are again within error of each other and
although they're outside of the error
versus the 5070 TI the real error is the
gpus we launched along the way the 5070
TI ends up leading the 105 FPS average
4070 TI super result by a staggering
mind-blowing
9.7% made only more impressive by the
fact that this was already functionally
the same as the 470 TI 100 FPS 7800 XT
it's just below this Starfield is up now
at 4K the 570 TI ran at 68 FPS average
this time allowing the 480 the important
distinction of uh being technically
better the 580 only leads the 570 TI by
12% here as well troublingly for the 570
TI in this test the 700 XT nearly
matches the 57 TI with the 700 XTX ahead
of it by 13% the 4070 TI super and 4070
TI aren't that different from each other
in this one either at 1440p the 480
super and 480 are exactly tied with the
480 sub super or as Nvidia calls it the
570 TI at 101 FPS average you might be
wondering why Nvidia would launch 348s
but Wonder not the more you
buy the more you save that's right
that's right the more 480s you buy the
more you save other people from buying
them the 5070 TI ends up basically tied
with the 700 XT the 700 XTX holds an
advantage at 11% ahead the 570 TI is
Improvement if you can call it that over
the 470 TI super is an impressively
boring 3.9% with the lead over the 470
TI at 11% that's again impressive mostly
because we're impressed Nvidia could
make something so impressively stagnant
at 1080p Starfield has the 5070 TI below
the XTX which has a slight lead at 6%
more impressively the 4070 TI super ran
at 120 FPS average between the 580 the
480s the 570 TI and the 470 TI super and
the 470 TI Nvidia has managed to make a
video card for seemingly every
individual frame rate between 110 and
132 FPS why they do this why we don't
know Dragon Dogma 2 is up now this one
has the Asus RTX 570 TI electrolyte
which is what the games crave at 73.6
FPS average that's right between the 480
super and 7900 XCX making the 570 TI the
first Nvidia RTX 480 super super on the
market we won't be impressed until they
launch the Triple S super tier the 580s
lead over the 57 TI is just 15% that
small of an uplift is going to weigh on
Nvidia everything I'm showing today are
very heavy the 570 TI leads the 470 TI
super by 18% and the 470 TI by 35% the
700 XT sits between the two 470 TI
variant 1440p reduces the 5070 TI's
relative ranking pushing it below the
480 and 480 super the two of which are
tied and within error of each other the
4070 TI suers 106 FPS average results
also makes for a boring positioning of
the 5070 TI again we're back to a card
for every couple FPS more than ever this
means price matters more the 700 XTX
leads the 570 TI by about 6 FPS here at
1080p the RTX 570 TI is 151 FPS average
basically ties it with the 700 XTX which
itself is tied with the 480 which is
tied with the 480 super which is a waste
of chart space on this one so it's not
shown generationally the 570 TI leads
the 470 TI super by 10% and 470 TI by
18% Resident Evil 4 is up now first
rasterized the 4K test has a 570 TI at
107 FPS average with 5080 at 122 and
leading by 15% both are behind the 700
XTX at 126 FPS average the 5070 TI is
ahead of the 4070 TI super by 20% and
the 4070 TI by 34% the 7800 XD is
between these and the regular 4070
followed by the older 3070 TI at 53 FPS
average at 1440p the 5070 TI is just
below the 480 the 5080 leads the 570 TI
by 133% Nvidia basically took what
previously would have been a 51 FPS Gap
from 224 to 173 FPS between the 4070 TI
super and 580 and then it split the
difference with the 570 TI the 7800 XTX
is ahead by 17% with the XT just below
the 5070 TI we're moving to R tracing
games now we'll start with black myth
which is heavily Nvidia favored and then
we'll look at some games that are mixed
or lighter workloads at 4K with
upscaling as defined in the chart header
the 570 TI ran at 52 FPS average and
tied the 480 and 480 super the 580 is 59
FPS result had it 13% ahead over the
4070 TI super we see a 15% lead for the
5070 TI AMD gets absolutely crushed in
this test unfortunately for them at
1080P and still R trace the 5070 TI ran
at 112 FP s average and led the 480 the
580 has improved on the 5070 TI by 9%
the proximity of cards from the 4070
through the 580 is crazy though we have
the 4070 at 80 FPS then the ti at 92
then the ti super at 95 then the 480 at
106 the 480 super which isn't shown but
is the same and then the 570 TI at 112
then we have the 58 at 122 FPS Dragons
Dogma 2 at 4K with Ray tracing is next
in this one the m00 XTX is more
competitive and lands at 66 FPS average
which is between the 580 and 570 TI it's
unfortunate that AMD gets crushed so
hard in some of the other games like
blacksmith Wukong cuz it does okay in
the ones that are less crazy intensive
the 5070 TI ends up basically tied with
a 480 super which is basically tied with
the 480 the jumper of the 4070 TI superp
54 FPS average is 18% here 1440p
positions the 5070 TI between the 4070
TI super and the 480 it's not clear why
this card needs to exist but it does the
Improvement against the 4070 TI super is
just
10.8% the 700 XTX runs at 108 FPS
average and is between the 480s and the
580 let's move on at 1080p the 5070 TI
ran at 131 FPS average and was roughly
tied with the 700 XTX the 480 leads the
570 TI here by a few perc the 570 TI
leads the 470 TI super by 9% followed by
the 7800 XT in the middle ground and
then the 470 TI at 16% and res Evil 4 at
4K with Ray tracing and upscaling the
5070 TI ran at 118 FPS average and tied
the 480 and 480 super exactly it's
within runto run variance and error the
7800 XTX leads in this lightweight RT
workload with a 14% Advantage posting a
big difference from the heavier
cyberpunk and black myth workloads that
we run at 1440p with the same settings
we see a similar lineup the 5070 TI is
again within error of the 480 and 480
super which are the same the 700x X is
slightly improved the 4070 TI super is
slightly behind and this is
uninteresting efficiency up now we've
explained this test in the past so we'll
just get to the results efficiency
remains a relatively new test for us to
include in each review so we haven't
rerun the 4070 cards for efficiency just
yet in Final Fantasy 14 at 4K the 5070
TI landed at 0.37 FPS per watt it pulled
264 watts in this test approaching its
TDP spec the 580 ends up slightly more
efficient with the 480 super equivalent
the 7900 XTX has at a large disadvantage
here due to its power consumption in
Final Fantasy 14 at 1440p the 55070 ti
ended up at 0.73 FPS per watt which has
it just below the 480 and 580 the 5070
TI improves on the 4060 glass cards but
also is significantly more efficient
than the 7900 XTX in black myth who
calling at 1080p we found the 5070 TI to
be between the 480 super and 580 for
efficiency the 7800 xdx shows again that
this is its weakness but its particular
performance deficiency in black myth in
general is hurting it disproportionately
in rate tracing performance with f124 we
found the 570 TI to perform about the
same as the 480 the 700 XTX score
significantly lower overall here you're
seeing much lower numbers than in some
of the other charts and that's because
there's a heavy rate tracing workload
tested with the higher resolution as
well all of this means that Nvidia is
basically just selling you an RTX 40
series card maintaining elevated prices
and doing so while pushing dss4 and MFG
as the only real differentiating Factor
on the 50 Series we already have a piece
up talking about the new transform model
versus the prior CNN model for dlss so
you can find that on the channel for a
deep dive but what you're looking at
right now and what you've been looking
at are some preview clips of our
upcoming video which we have 100%
completed and it's going up likely
tomorrow with an image quality
comparison this includes a frame by fake
frame breakdown of MFG where we analyze
the AI or the synthetic or the fake
frames against the key frames or the
native frames we do this at two 2X and
with MFG 4X some of which you're seeing
on the screen now and the improvements
of things like the transform model over
the older CNN model for image quality
are apparent meanwhile the generated
frames serve their purpose of smoothing
but sometimes look bad what they don't
do is turn 20 FPS or 25 or 30 FPS or
whatever into an instantly playable
great frame rate this is something we
described in our previous piece but as
far as the image quality it's highly
situational in some situations dlss ends
up better than native because game
developers have decided to ruin their
games with terrible default options
which shouldn't happen but there's also
a lot of scenarios where it looks awful
we found bugs in the driver override as
well that Nvidia has pushed to the
public this includes sometimes it
incorrectly running the generated frames
in the wrong places that'll all be in
our image quality video though this
quick thermal chart looks at steady
state during a looping 4K Port Royal
workload and it shows the GPU and memory
results we don't have other 5070 TI
cards to compare so we can't produce a
like for like comparison the 580s are
only here for reference the 570 TI came
in 2 DBA quieter than the Zotac 580
solid and it was warmer while operating
at a significantly lower reported power
during the test the Asus cooler is
favoring noise here but it's also just
not particularly effective overall the
performance is fine this is more than
acceptable and well below throttle
territory but this does seem to be one
of the lower cost coolers for its size
acoustic testing is up next we'll keep
this brief as quickly as possible our
chamber is about to get way better for
feature testing or more accurately our
microphone equipment we've recently
learned that with a microphone upgrade
we can bring down the noise floor closer
to 5 DBA which is crazy exciting
currently though we're on our more
economical equipment with the current
noise floor of 14 to 145 DBA we measured
the Asus 570 TI Prime at 29.2 DBA with
this frequency spectrum plot we observed
one Spike at around 300 htz otherwise it
follows what we've seen in other C the
falloff begins at 2,000 Herz levels
briefly at 3500 to 5,000 then continues
the path the loudest range is 1,00 HZ to
1800 HZ aside from the 300 hzz Spike
these two lines show the Zotac 580 and
Nvidia 590 Fe the cooler should track
about the same as long as the fan RPM is
the same between the other 580 and 590
Alternatives by the same vendor then
video card had a spike around 180 HZ and
another at around 380 HZ the Zotac card
had one in the 30 HZ range and broadly
the Nvidia Fe is louder than both of
these this will change as the prices
move in the future but we don't review
the future we review what's shipping and
reality and currently reality says that
this entire situation is obsurd and for
those of you who've been around a long
time watching GN first thank you but
secondly you might remember this it
feels an awful lot like sort of the 2020
era of GPU launches for now the simple
version is we don't recommend buying the
5070 TI not only because the pricing is
just I it's just not great I mean you're
looking at the third or fourth iteration
of a 4080 now and it's really not that
different in what the real world actual
street price is going to be and that's
even in the future ignoring uh the
initial launch frenzy so we just don't
recommend it uh but let's just recap as
quickly as possible some of the data for
those of you who jumped here broadly
speaking we found out the 80 performance
in the range of 9% to 16% better than
the 570 TI depending on the resolution
of the game the 7900 XX is often better
than the 5070 TI and Riz testing with
the range in our games spanning
equivalence to 17% at the high end but
more commonly 6% to 133% there were some
instances of regression for the 7900 XTX
versus the 5070 TI but as has been the
case it only really got crushed in black
myth or cyberpunk type R tracing the 570
TI only improves on the 47 TI super by a
range of 3.9% or 2.2 if you go down to
1080P and that wasn't even CPU bound to
20% at the highest end and it's often 12
to 16% if you're looking at the heavier
resolutions that is not a good
Improvement for a generational jump
especially considering the important
factor that we're talking about sort of
the the middle of the average range that
means there's worse improvements like we
just mentioned and the actual street
price as expected to the 4070 TI Su
original Street pricing so Street to
Street pricing we're not talking MSRP to
Street here especially with instances
below 10% performance it's an awful
value remember that the Super Series was
regularly in stock for its actual MSRP
and so the actual price of the 5070 TI
we can't see it in advance in a review
uh we we don't review the future we
don't know what the prices will land on
launch day around when the video goes up
but based on what we've seen with the
580 and 590 our strongest recommendation
right now just wait in general to buy a
video card just let it calm down uh
anyway finally the 570 TI is equal to
the 480 super we don't care what MSRP
the 480 was it was stupid uh the 480
super effectively overwrote that MSRP
and that was $1,000 and it was actually
available around $950 to $1,050 for a
lot of its life recently especially at
the $950 Mark before it went out of
stock now for the rest I AMD really
needs to not [__] this up and uh we're
not sure what they're going to do so it
comes down to pricing AMD traditionally
has taken this really strange approach
where they change the prices sometimes
within literal days of launch and
sometimes like 3 months after launch but
it's basically an accepted constant that
whatever AMD says its price is it's
going to come down in like one quarter
because they're going to push it way too
high they're going to do that Nvidia
minus 50 bucks and for some reason
realize once again oh wait that's not
good enough because they just buy
there's already Nvidia minus 50 bucks
it's other Nvidia so AMD really can't
screw this up for the rest of us uh but
we don't know what that outcome is going
to be they have publicly said they're
not going to make a high on this
generation deeply disappointing because
you look at the 7900 xdx on these charts
now where at launch uh the 700xt and the
XTX it was easy to be critical of them
but then you look at the follow-ups like
when we did a 700 XT followup it was 700
bucks or something and it started to
become more favorable and so it's that
regular tick of AMD chooses a price has
absolutely no confidence in it and it it
gets shaken into a lower price pretty
quickly thereafter and again sometimes
even before the launch technically uh so
we don't know what they're going to do
but this they are part of this
discussion too because Nvidia is able to
do the things it does because it
controls the market and it's not is
responsibility to let its competitors
catch up likewise if its competitors
don't want to they're happy with status
quo or they're off doing data center or
whatever then fine but as a consumer we
just think right now is not a good time
to buy a GPU there are some positives
the positives are on the overclocking
side uh if you're on an older generation
C depending on what generation it is
there is sometimes a huge amount of
headro where on the lower end you might
be looking at like 10% gains or
something but if you really spend some
time on an OC or especially you start
digging around for custom v bioses a lot
of caveat that' be careful of but you
start doing stuff like that and you go
back far enough there were times when
you get like 20 to 30% gains uh from a
card and we've shown some of that
recently with one of our 1080 TI
revisits I think it was so there's some
room there don't forget about
overclocking to just try and stretch the
life out a little longer if you're kind
of like on that edge where it's a little
stuttery in the games you like but it's
not completely unplayable you might be
able to just do some tuning and try to
stretch it one more generation which is
something we'd always recommend uh
obviously if you want to build a
computer just because it's fun go for it
but if you don't need to and you have no
interest in doing that you just want to
be able to play the games at a frame
rate you like and you're on the
borderline keep that in mind another
thing that's positive is that there are
a lot of interesting and good components
launching right now it just seems to be
the GPU Market that's totally [__] so
on the CPU side the 9800 activity is
very exciting and the 590 kind of
continually proved that because it could
actually keep up even in some of these
1080p situations and then uh coolers
cases we've gotten into fan testing
that's really fun so trying to throw out
some like hey there's positive stuff
that's going on it just does not appear
to be in the GPU market right now we've
been through these Cycles before uh
we'll go through them again and really
it's just that these these vendors they
need to be kicked in the ass a little
bit uh to realize like oh wait like
we've we've found the limit of what the
market will bear and we need to adjust
anyway that's my spiel for this one so
uh our recommendation don't buy it and
subscribe more go to store. Gamers
access.net to help us out directly
because
um well I don't think I did tell people
not to watch this video like three
minutes into it so that's it subscribe
for more thanks for watching we'll see
you all next time